- This is a cute dress too.
- Thank you, thank you.
I actually busted the belt,
so we just had to sew
it in the car, you know.
But we're here, we're doing it, thank you.
- Meet Tinashe, meet Jeff.
- Hi guys.
- So Jeff's family named him Chex Mix.
So how did you get the name Tinx?
- So when I was younger, I
actually wasn't that confident.
And so I watched this movie
and there was a character in this movie
called All I Wanna Do,
called Tinker Parker.
And she was like the coolest girl.
And I told my friends,
I was like, guys I have an alter ego now,
her name is Tinker Parker.
And when I'm her, I'm confident
and I'm cool and whatever.
And slowly I just started
to become more confident
and slowly they just started
to call me Tinker Parker
then Tinker then Tinx.
So I've been called Tinx
for like 20 years now.
- That's cute.
- Yeah, yeah.
Its like my Sasha Fierce moment, you know?
- Yeah.
- We all need a nickname and alter ego.
- It is funny.
I don't know if y'all feel
this when you're on stage
but I do feel like different
and I do feel more bold and confident.
Do you feel like that
when you're on stage?
- Absolutely, there's
like this part of me,
I call her Nashe,
I just drop like the
first syllable of my name.
And like she this like super confident.
It's weird cause it lives
inside of you already.
But it gives the opportunity
to feel like you can kind of--
- Absolutely.
- Step into that, you know?
- Yeah.
- [Tinashe] So much.
- Do you feel like that
on stage more confident?
- Yeah, I just feel like
I'm talking to my friends
so I look forward to it.
- Oh, I think that's why
people love you though too,
cause you're so relatable in that sense.
It's conversational.
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Everybody loves everybody here.